this moment where i was always just
joking and when a phone call came in
that
john favreau wanted to sit down with me
i almost had a heart attack i i
it took me halfway through that meeting
to realize that he was actually talking
about
me doing bokeh tan
i i just i i remember sitting across
from him total autobot
experience i remember sitting across
from him and just thinking to myself
this is what is he is he oh those are
pictures of me
on the wall why why are there what is
happening oh he's still talking
wait what is he talking about what what
is going on like it was
it was crazy um
and i still to this day i'm still
pinching myself my mind is blown
that not only did they have the thought
to do this but that they
they they believed that i could and then
they they ultimately
let me did they did he offer you the
role in the room
yeah i think so what did he say like
what was it what
was it okay was it a hey so would you do
this
i think it was something like that and
like i said i was so out of body
i really i don't remember
um but i do believe it was something
along
um the lines of like now is this
something you would be interested in
like don't
don't feel like you have to say yes but
is this something that you
that interests you did you play it cool
did you try
and i like touched my finger on the
table and i was like you got to be
kidding me
like of course i'll do this like i think
i was so
shocked did he smile did he say it all
right all right
of course he did oh my god he's such a
warm
oh yeah he's awesome john's awesome
amazing and he's such a phenomenal
director and he's a
fantastic actor and he's you know one of
the things that i loved
love about working with him so much as
he has this beautiful way
of giving you direction
that is motivating
and exciting um even if it's
if it's a critique on what you did it
doesn't come across as
it comes across as um hey that was
amazing i'm so excited
let's go over here because this is
exciting too um
and he just naturally does it and it's
it's a beautiful
he's he's so good at what he does i
wanna i wanna actually say thank you to
john favreau right now because
star wars you know it's you know for me
and
millions and millions of others it's
it's
it's so close to home and it's just it
is home and it's and then so some of
those new
the prequels and things like that they
didn't necessarily hit it and i was
people were frustrated and this and that
there's a lot of reasons and some were
better than others
but when i watched the mandalorian and
expecting
probably something similar i was
absolutely blown away to the point where
i
felt like a child again watching
the jawas for the first time watching
these these
it just was the practicals the vision
extraordinary if you haven't watched the
mandalorian you are missing out even if
you're not a star wars fan
it doesn't matter it's so well made so
well directed produced
written acted and now katie sakoff is
playing beau
katan and just a little histo first
before we get to the history of boca tan
because i want to talk a little bit
about that
but i wish there was a camera on your
face
when you walked out you're you're back
to him to
favro walking out to your car because i
what i do know about you is that you
probably got in your car and probably
teared up and got really excited
and gave yourself some fist bumps and
like oh my god i wanted to call
robin immediately and say forget about
the prenup listen
this is this it went so well i think i
might have got it i don't know i don't
want to jinx it but i think i did i
don't know
what would you do i think i still at
that moment like i'm
i i try to be really self-aware a lot
and i think i remember thinking to
myself they could still see you
they could still see you they could
still see you
i could just drive away drive away i
like started the car
and like you know i kept trying to put
it in like drive and i hadn't even like
you know
turned the car on yet and i kept trying
to like like okay and i just got far
enough away where they couldn't see me
and i called robin and i was like oh my
god
you